this is the last episode of daredevil if
you hear a little bit of a lawnmower in
the bag that's because oh folks but yeah
it all leads up to speed climb as Fisk
is finally put away and daredevil
finally gets us off and on and they had
this great big fight and Fisk is stuck
looking at his wall again now which was
a nice touch um yeah I mean the love
that these you're like what Vanessa
brakes about them like know I was almost
waiting for that shadowy guy from the
amazing spider-man movies the puppets
like you know there's been the
complication is that yeah we're never
gonna find out who you are but now
they're probably the biggest biggest
disappointment I also have never find
out who that guy is it amazing
spider-man though um really the Affleck
outfit look better it's tradition the
suit has to suck you know yeah there's
so little you can do with it it is a
tough one to make good it clearly just
belongs in a comic but I wanted to
believe nobody believed but Marvel has
done so well at taking these terrible
like obviously couldn't exist in reality
costumes and make them look cool
Thor looks cool Captain America got cool
you know they actually started to make
them cool at daredevil and they just
couldn't pull it off man hopefully they
can fix that I can see why they say
different the last episode cuz it's like
we can't have this running around yeah
so in some ways I'm grateful they say
good to the last episode because now
maybe they can fix it you have you're
doing a whole other season you have a
break in between on time fix it oh my
god but the but on the other hand I was
just like wow I waited a whole season to
get to that cast yeah well you see about
some of the advertisements like those
they'll put the costume on there and
even then very few though because
they're like no no we just go with the
black mask you know that yes
what kind of silly so I mean it's it's
about as good as you can do with that
outfit I just I don't know what else you
can do but yeah it's just why would he
put the horns on top why are the guy
designed there's like and little horns
and little you know it's I was waiting
for Potter to be like your symbol sucks
or you know um in the opening with the
red blood or Guin absolutely good yeah
that looks kind of yeah they have to be
summoned between that and designed in
the intro at least from the backside
that's all we get to see look not too
bad so yeah it's like I have the answer
it's a holiday anybody goes because if
anybody had the answer we never really
cool daredevil costume and we still
haven't gotten one know that the closest
is the movie which I actually don't hate
I think that one almost works but yet
it's just a little something that just
Milton and it might be something that
you just can't translate it would make
Captain America work they can make Jared
on if they could make for work they can
make daredevil work I just don't know
how I don't know how to do it like it's
wrong no nobody does somebody's got to
you person watching right now
costume designer design I don't know
you're watching go fix it apply tender
plates and make your dream come true now
watch like some person like we're gonna
find out next year it's just like oh my
god I followed my dreams I applied and
they said that I was too aggressive and
will never work in this town again so
thanks a lot asshole um that was quite a
tangent you when I'm there yeah sorry uh
but anywho um a good final episode I
really liked the the FBI coming in I
liked him trying to escape the coolest
stuff is when the FBI turns around
starts shooting each other just gets out
of that car with the yeah yeah the coat
floating in the was a whole Good
Samaritan thing just all this time I
thought I was the Samaritan but I have
not him nor the religious man
so no thalles on I like that he's come
to grips with it he's like nah I'm
you'll intent that's it's you know if he
gets to be the Good Samaritan because
they kept cutting to Murtagh it's like
if he gets to be the Good Samaritan then
I'm beyond intent I have purpose I'd be
lying if I said like the last night was
good don't get me wrong and it's like
I'm glad they didn't push out it just
feel like that's time or I half-assed I
kind of like you know in the movie but
at the same time it's like with all the
action sequences we have before I feel
like if I said I wasn't kind of waiting
for something a little different order
to be up to bit it's basically I'll
fight that's not bad but it's not an
issue is great it could have been better
choreographed I didn't think it was shot
exceptionally well a core group
exceptionally well considering what
we've answered yeah the funny thing is
if this were any other show everybody's
already awesome but this show set the
bar is so freakin high that yeah it
didn't feel like a letdown because it
still felt very no island and but I will
say this what I did really like about it
is the set design on it the fact that it
happens in a back alley somehow feels so
right yeah to me um particularly because
what they they did this thing where it's
it's lit up with the same yellow and
orange lights off set against blue and
then they have these it's like plastic
bags or something that ran up again the
winds yeah chain-link fence or something
it was a nice effect it literally looked
like fire and like instantly I'm like I
get it I know what they're doing and it
was fun because Fisk for so long has
been in this ivory tower and he only
steps out when he needs to work amongst
you know his little minions or whatever
like Satan walking amongst his little
demons but for the most part he's always
in this White Tower he's he's always in
this sort of sterile environment and
everything's kind of like cleaning
around him and I like that
he's almost gotten away and like Murdock
has literally literally visually dragged
him back into hell and it's like this
fight in this back alley with like you
know fire kind of around
I thought it was a nice touch doing that
you know here's the fine thing you know
open the better setup because I got a
lil excited when I saw it and then they
didn't do too much with it but they
weren't really supposed to when he
approaches gal when he approaches her
and there's this fire in the background
they just look at each other for a
second then she's just like this often
you know he's down which is a cool
moment but I'm thinking like now replace
her with Fisk that'd be pretty awesome
seeing the real fire behind them and
stuff while Joe's everything's going to
shit but that's that's really bad pinky
that's definitely demo eight I think
some and maybe do some homage is to
nolan going on yeah I'm like that escape
I'm just like that seems directly out of
darkness what you know with the truck
flipping yeah we got out there took me
Mifare is when the truck flips over
there the end done just goes I'm upside
down somebody put me right side the you
know you could say anything it is noise
they would just be hilarious yeah I am a
little teapot short and start where the
pound puppies and then want to come home
with you it's gonna be like yep don't we
saw the room we're just gonna be honest
trailers voice guys like say things in
this ways we do is say things and Wilson
yeah I'm a pretty pretty princess with
my pretty princess I'll see what's he a
half no okay um but okay but the one
thing I was saying at the beginning of
this and I really felt it at the end why
don't they just tell Karen like this is
actually causing more trouble that is
preventing you know dunno just don't get
comic books dude baby
I mean it awesome foggy knows by now
well why the fuck not Karen I mean
there's someone else in a genius for a
second season
I know wow so see where she comes in and
she's like they're trying to fear
something she's so determined and he
they're trying to well I don't know
anything cuz I'm a lawyer nothing like
there's so much it you could tell him
there's so much it you could work off of
each other as daredevil you know to go
and do this other stuff even like how
he'd communicate with foggy and stuff
like look you need to trust me if
there's just something I need to do this
is a time where I need to go as variable
and stuff and it's like why not do that
see with her because she's clearly you
know in it all the way she was clearly
gonna push herself as far as she can go
she's already been in tons of danger you
know and half the time has got out of it
herself I mean so it's like it we're
good weekend it's just damn I the comic
book guy in me gets it um the person
that wants a strong narrative and a
fulfilling story couldn't agree with you
more
yeah I like particularly like I get
saving it but I'm like this episode that
needed to happen yeah like early on I
get it I get it not even by bothers me
because he can see how destroyed she's
getting and flipping out over everything
I think that would have helped her I
think had she known I'm the I'm the guy
I I am the guy in the mask I'm here we
can do this together we're all working
to get that would have put her mind way
more at ease rather than well I guess
somehow we're gonna have to find a way
to work it out you know there's a scene
wait Johnny not not telling her just
there's a scene where they're all
talking it's almost douchey with yeah
they're all talking about finger plans
and something it's like you know me your
guy in the mask will find them it's like
you know we heard it from you know your
friend in the best really you saw what's
you look oh well if he dropped by and
you know like you're glad you're a kid
about that really that was the perfect
blow and I just want him to go like Iron
Man just let go you know it's me
yeah what about a great moment I'm I
just said yeah what a big boy he just
come found him right there under oh you
know cuz we it's not okay because oh
it's that thing where you kind of know
now it's not gonna hold up anymore
especially after I mean really you know
you always we always talk about Dark
Knight a Batman Begins these movies that
define a lot at and broke a lot new
ground
in my opinion honestly the end of Iron
Man just where he says I'm Iron Man I
mean it's like that's a huge holy shit I
remember when we all saw that anything
like wait a minute where the hell does
it go from here it was such a you know
total opposite of one every superhero
name is Iron Man 3 well do technically
um first do this o to this oh yeah you
did then 1 yeah you did that in
waterways I mean the comic book movies I
was trying to go through the list I mean
2 & 3 are so forgettable nobody would
know but that's the thing like at the
very end of it yeah it's like it's
suddenly like hey this cliche doesn't
really work anymore like we get it we
got what you did for a while we know why
you usually have to keep it a secret but
it's like only works out as a story
divide it it doesn't make sense though
it just that so that it could work if it
makes sense Peter Parker not telling
Aunt May makes sense how is that gonna
help Aunt May's life any it ain't like
so in those movies it makes sense here
it makes no sense because it would have
helped Karen out it would have solved a
lot of problems it would have fixed a
lot of things so if they got like so
many quarters if he doesn't make sense
then don't do it you sister sometimes
you have to do just what works perfectly
with getting the of the story you know
sometimes I'm tumblr you see those
little quotes you know I want just fuck
the comics Ron Walker and like said no
some people would be like you know oh he
doesn't understand but yeah I know
there's a lot of people be like right on
works doesn't work in the context of
story you wanna know why spider-man
three suck it didn't work in the context
of the story it has nothing to do with
the fact that they change things from
the comics if you again I always say
this if you make a change from the
comics that is at least lateral and at
best better than the comics I'm
completely over these works in the
environment yes my the spider-man 3
sucked because they change things from
the comics and it didn't even work in
the context of the story they were
trying to tell in spider-man 1 and 2 it
was fuckin stupid now if you want us to
have him tell Karen in this story
then he's daredevil right at this point
in the story it makes
fucking Santa I don't care if it's
different from the comics like I just
don't
it would I actually made this story
better you know makes the story better
than do it I'm almost wondering because
they shoot different versions of
everything and stuff but you never know
what time I'm almost wondering they shot
a version where they did where he does
tell her because you got a wonder my my
guess is there may be versions out there
where he does and my other thing is
they've already changed so many other
things from the copy yeah why Rick's
dead in this one you know he's bled in
the comics I think he's a white guy
Urich um so do his work look them up
again I thought I could be wrong don't
get me wrong I'm not he was like point
being they they changed things in the
comics Potter was a bad guy originally
like so they they change things already
and Fisk definitely his best or he is
different
um so why not this but yeah so why not
that my guess is they my guess is it
doesn't have anything to do with the
comics cuz they change other things my
guess is they're just like well we gotta
save something yeah people come back
this um um because they're obviously
developing this romantic interest
between the two so which I want him to
get with I'm sorry Dawson yeah she's
good
yeah I mean Karen's cool don't get me
wrong kind of nearly night nurse yeah I
don't know she just seemed like yeah
yeah you know what I maybe you'll be
like Peter Parker and Shadowcat and Mary
Jane it's like there's someone for a
daredevil there's something for a
Murdock you know her stuff felt like
that which really choose um but I know I
could be wrong uh by I guess she already
kind of shot him down didn't she well
she took off so far so yeah she kind of
said well be there to patch you up but
yeah issues with you know Catholic guilt
written boys who like to beat the shit
out of other people the save their city
like she didn't have a martyr complex
like he did so yeah um by the way those
are the best lines in this episode
actually the whole show all together
just how you taken it like a good
Catholic boy
yeah
yeah great I love that phrase that
proves the other great line along those
lines was um what the hell it was it
went foggy sounds like you weren't
either going to have to kill this guy or
no even this guy is gonna kill you or
you're gonna have to kill him and if you
kill him as a Catholic that's gonna kill
you anything
Oh Catholic guilt you know what I
realized with that with that priest
because I'm thinking like we've seen
this kind of priest character a million
times the supportive kind of edgy kind
of breaks the rules a little bit buts
got a good heart and stuff actually I
like him because he's not bad no no what
I like is not a hip priest he's just
kind of tells away no buzz but that's
one say there are so many characters
like that and he no but that's usually
him priests who they tell it like it is
it's up he doesn't feel that way he
feels like a real person even though
he's kind of playing the archetype that
he's like a little cynic
he doesn't seem constructed out of the
kind of cliche grab bag he feels like a
real person
yeah we need the young hip priests like
okay you know what I'm thinking of me
wasn't the priest but spider-man 2 and
the doctors doctor and I share the fuck
did this hipster doctor compromise this
is like something only an alleyway all
the people have movie it's like nobody
in that movie existed in reality which I
know Calvin book movie goofy I get it it
works in it was like the inside was also
hit but that's the thing I don't get the
idea that the priest is hip I get he's
an old cynical person but he's also just
honest with himself and others yeah like
you know he's in a bad neighborhood he
has to kind of do what he can to keep
the spirits high but be realistic you
know um but ya know I thought it was a I
thought was a decent wrap-up decent
climax it was nice seeing Fisk is come
up it's a it's nice I really like when
he says you know she's like no we can do
it no Twitter there is no avoiding this
you know this is going to happen this ya
know I know I love that Russian although
it's like no I got it we can still work
out this but this is not being a void
I have to take this punch you know and
it's gonna be really bad play a whole
boxer metaphor yeah no I really like
that I like that rationale especially
because he's had so many emotional
moments bring a box metaphor when he
falls to the ground never mind to me of
earlier scenes with the bonds yeah it is
it's like a ko well and I again he cares
more she is the only thing that I think
he cares more about than himself like he
had a vision about Wesley well okay he
cared about was he but I mean now all
that's left is basically her and he's
pretty much things like you're not
coming to jail with me yeah like this
isn't the the you know if he involves
her it is like we flee together I think
he knew well then she's an accessory
yeah so it's like I have to get arrested
whatever I do I do alone like we can run
away together after the fact but no the
one thing that I'm yourself I know I'm
so bad when I turn it off I we forget to
turn it on then I'm just like a million
calls so that's why I do that for anyone
wondering I know it's annoying um it's
just my bad memory but when I know it
wasn't gonna say I get my bad memory um
oh no I remember okay when they so it's
showing the three of them you know
they're back together
I kind of accordi a few corny lines and
you know can we move past this no but
maybe we can move forward lame the scene
where she said this is how it should be
you know back together it's a lame-o but
with that said well this show is so dark
I think we could don't no no lameness
you know it was like a wink like see we
could have fun no but that's why I like
seeing Todd can work off each other and
you know without having to state the
ions you busy with I was with her I
actually missed him and foggy I was
actually kind of shocked how much I
missed it too when I got I saw him back
together I was kind like yeah you know I
did miss this a little bit this is this
room for foggy um but when it cuts back
to to Fisk in his car I merely thought
wow so is it gonna come back
go or the Russians of an item on rush
nobody's guys dead well I guess is why
he is the kingpin yeah it was family I
really thought about how many characters
died in this like they got we have a lot
of characters I mean none like super
super main like the main four or five
but it's like everyone else pretty much
they never have a lot of people um so
but yeah I the the last thing I'll say
cuz I mean all these characters are
really good but the one that is like I
don't know it's been a while since I've
had a character especially in a show
where every time it cut back to him I
was excited and intrigued and that
really was foggy no yeah yeah fine yeah
no it really was kingpin every single
time he cut it we cut back to him like I
got excited what we were gonna discover
what he was in a do well what we were
going I do feel bad because it was a
trifecta of characters it was kingpin
Gao Wesley if they were in a scene as
far as I was concerned that I liked I my
eyes just lit up and I'm just like ooh
what's gonna happen care yeah just those
who are incredible Leland or the
Russians the Russians are kind of boring
actually but it it was just when every
one of those three was on screen I was
just always fascinated it's kind of like
I could have watched those three all day
yeah it's like Zuko or or IRA it's like
any time those three are on it's like
you get excited in Avatar it's like the
same thing and again they're all the
moments definitely so but I guess former
villain yeah yeah but I'm a villain but
ya know it's one of those things where
it's like I really like when you see a
character and you just just their
appearance you're like ooh and this
character after episode 3 is in every
episode and he's in it a lot so that's
really impressive that every single time
he pops up I get excited to see him like
I'm really really you know ain't just
like you know what's gonna happen max
I'm so excited what what's he gonna say
what's he gonna do how does he get this
I like the baby
I know some people were just like oh
well he's kind of weak and he falls in
love with his woman things fall apart
and he speaks funny and like I loved it
he just owned it I mean he just owned it
in that performance and the writers and
the directors I mean they just it is
very but they just made him so
fascinating I'm sorry he's still a scary
motherfucker when he strangles Urich I
was like holy shit like the way it looms
under his faces I like it
I love cuz I feel for age ya know cuz
like he brought up the the threat
element he's just like you know oh it's
like what let me just get these words
out cuz I admire you I have to say these
words before I kill you the old you
brought my mother into a good so I'm not
going to 3 all that this why I'm going
to kill me oh it's like okay now I can
kill you and let's go but you can see
I'm like I need to get these words out
cuz that's the honorable thing and I
respect you is that but you are going to
die and the scary thing is always
somebody who is logical has it together
but can snap yeah like I find that way
more sphere like somebody who's just
like oh I'm just evil and I can do this
you always feel that somehow you could
reason with somebody like that not
always we always feel like maybe you can
reason with him but somebody that
unhinged like you thought he had it made
he's like uh I work this out perfectly
so now you can't kill him and he's like
he didn't Bank on the fact that no he's
fucking nuts he'll kill him anyway that
to me is way scarier because this is
like there's no reasoning with this guy
who's in the logic logic would have said
leave Leland alive because you don't
want to take the risk of you know giving
em another way or figure out another but
no it doesn't make sense to kill him and
then look for the guy after I and it
didn't it turned out it fit him in the
ass um but the you know the scene I
think this episode or I think was Prior
where Wesley's Wesley the other guy I'm
the guy in there Wesley was told to stay
behind he's like you let him go alone
it's like you know it was an order he
told us to stay behind so it just gives
him this look of course head boy yes my
friend that's my friend and of course
you know sorry sorry you know
give him an extra bonus or something and
of course the guy still sticks around
doing just great but like I was just
like you know attacking me because I'm a
loser but there was there was kind of
like this weirdness to that scene
because I got this strange impression I
have everybody else out this way but the
guy kind of took it and I always
wondered if this guy is so loyal that
he's like no he means this this is good
he didn't realize it yeah like and I
mean maybe he just was not been
conscious and sleeping so she likes me
with it but yeah I'm just like man if
somebody was really whaling on me I
would think I would try to do it but
yeah so I am almost wondering if like
these guys are so well that's like no
it's okay need some work through it yeah
so yeah any final thoughts here I I just
love this show beginning to end I hope I
hope Marvel does more of this in the
same way DC's got the flash and arrow
going like I hope thinking outside of
their boxes helps because right now I am
starting to hit that moment of like kind
of comic book movie fatigue and I'm
feeling like yes yeah like they're good
but it's like this time we'll see what
Batman versus Superman has in store I
actually was on a few who didn't hate
the trailer looking at it so I'm going
to give it a fair shake but yeah I hope
we see more like this in might my only
concern is like now I know this talk of
like oh they may do an iron fish fish in
fists iron I don't see that iron fist
show and there's talks about you know
lady gal being the crane mother I like
and there's talking about more shows and
like bringing this into the larger
Marvel comic universe and I I'm not
gonna lie what I like about this show is
the fact that it's not really that
connected to the rest of the MCU and the
fact that it has a distinct lack of
supernatural things going on we had that
hint with the kid that was brought in
and I still don't know what that's
supposed to be if it's some reference
it's over my head but that
and was bringing in I I'm kind of hoping
that I don't know like they could do it
and they did this and this was awesome
and maybe they'll bring in all these
other shows and make it part of the MCU
and all these supernatural elements in
this and add an iron fist and then
serpent and maybe it'll be good
I mean maybe you'll be really awesome
and I'll be like ah see I love them
worry about I kind of like this because
it wasn't doing that oh yeah it was it
was different it was trying to I'm
hopeful in future seasons it does just
doesn't become like every other Marvel
property because right now this feels
fresh it feels different and I'm hoping
they kind of stay that route and if if
I'm wrong I'm wrong and I'll be very
happy I'll totally be like I had nothing
worried about that was awesome but if
I'm right and they do then and it just
kind of becomes like everything else a I
don't know it's not gonna be as much fun
to me like this felt cool because it was
so gritty and kind of yeah the rest of
that MCU universe yeah um no I I really
enjoyed it especially the villains but
the hero is is so smart and so likable
as well that I think that I mean that
all the characters are pretty light we
talked about various varying levels of
likable we talked about fists but really
Murdock was amazing as well and we have
I think because he does it so well you
know the Fisk is the role where you can
choose scenery Murdock as a character he
doesn't have that same luxury and I
think we forget he does it so well we
don't talk about it much but I loved him
throughout the whole series
ya know you did very well and and it's
shot grain it's very it's like Sin City
with even more color in the shadows but
still such a respect from that darkness
as well and it kept me interested in
every single episode I not being a huge
comic book reader but knowing enough you
know about like kingpin and daredevil
stuff I like most of the changes they've
done and I'm curious to see where
they're gonna go and yeah it was just
great fun I love what Netflix is doing
with these shows
slub they can kind of do whatever they
want they know it and they're just
they're opening up more and more and
this is why they're ruling TV anymore I
then move around with most of the
changes killing Yuriko off kind of
bugged me I bet that one felt a little
trophy to me almost feeling the support
of black guy yeah joe black Supporting
Actor and honestly I'm surprised I'm
surprised like tropes go like putting
two cuz I'm pretty sure he's still alive
in the comic universe I'm like so I on
the one hand it surprised me I didn't
think they were gonna do it but I'm
having a disappointing because it's like
I didn't think they were gonna do it
because it seemed kind of dumb for a
show normally this good um I'm hoping
they develop pot or more cuz they
changed that from the comics but I never
felt I got to know Potter I never felt
like it it's he's almost an easter egg
in the show so far maybe they'll do more
with him but yeah everything else like
as I said it's been so many it's been
decades now I think at this point since
I've read their devil so going off of
memory like it seemed pretty close to
what I remember at least some of the
Miller years and you know before that
when it was lighter and I really enjoyed
it so you know definitely fun thank you
guys for joining us uh after this we're
going to Steven universe we've been
getting a lot of people ask us to do
this we can probably get them out faster
and easier because in my written third
like they're short yeah ten fifteen
minutes on my bed we can do a like
adventure time and just go I'm looking
but I'm looking forward to it it's gonna
be another long haul though yeah I know
I here's a lot of episodes but I mean
what I saw I was very intrigued by and
I'm really looking forward to and it
apparently a lot of our people do it'll
be curious to see if this is like a
really really big audience for it that
wants to see these feed logs are just a
really vocal minority because sometimes
it's really hard to tell but the show
the episodes I saw were really
fascinating and I'm really looking
forward to that so so if you want a lot
of Steven universe watch it and tell
your hash share spread all that's
definitely encourage us to do more so
please put them how faster so yeah
that's about it and
we'll see you next time later